Hey youtuber’s it’s charlie Happy Thanksgiving.
I hope you’ve all had a chance to see the
Doctor Who 50th Anniversary episode.
Because so much of the show’s history was
incorporated into it I thought it would be
fun to go on an easter egg hunt.
Since there are so many I broke this video
into two parts.
Be sure to subscribe to get part 2 I’ll
be posting it on Saturday.
I’ll also be doing a video next week analyzing
some of the bigger theories about who exactly
the Peter Capaldi Doctor will be.
Now these easter eggs are in chronological
order of appearance.
Since they span the television series, audio
adventures and comic books I’ll include
a reference for where things can be found.
Here we go.
1.
The Title sequence from the first season of
Doctor who in 1963.
(TV Show, Season 1 1963)
2.
The sign Totter’s Lane was where the William
Hartnell Doctor hid his tardis after fleeing
gallifrey with his granddaughter susan foreman.
(TV Show, same)
3.
I.M Foreman was a gallifreyan monk living
on earth after being driven out by Rassilon’s
Intuitive Revolution.
He formed a traveling show using 13 different
aspects from all of his regenerations and
crossed paths with Sarah Jane Smith and the
third doctor.
( Interference Book 1 & 2 1999)
4.
Ian Chesterton.
One of the Doctor’s earliest companions
from the very first episode.
He later became a science teacher at Coal
Hill in the 1960s.
He went on to have future adventures with
the fifth and eleventh doctors.
5.
W Coburn.
Anthony Coburn was the writer of the very
first Doctor Who episode.
An Unearthly child.
6.
No More is written on Clara’s blackboard.
7.
The Clock reads 5:15PM That was the time the
first episode of doctor who aired.
8.
The motorbike.
Clara riding it into the tardis is something
the doctor did during the tv movie.
9.
Clara closes the doors to the tardis by snapping
her fingers.
Something only river song used to be able
to do.
10.
Cocktails on the Moon.
There is a UNIT Base on the moon manned by
Elizabeth Shaw (sarah jane adventures, the
death of the doctor).
11.
Osgood’s scarf.
This is the fourth doctor’s scarf.
Osgood is Kate Stewart’s daughter, who in
turn got the scarf from her father who got
it from the fourth doctor.
Who looks mysteriously like the museum curator.
12.
The doctor hangs outside of the tardis while
it flies over london monuments.
Just like in matt smith’s first full episode
the eleventh hour.
13.
The 3D Painting.
No More, Gallifrey Falls.
The 3D aspect and the plot device, saving
bits of things frozen in spacetime is from
the episode Nightmare of eden from the fourth
doctor’s run.
Who looks mysteriously like the museum curator.
Yet again…
14.
A Weapon with a conscience.
This is a reference to a douglas adams story
Life The Universe and Everything.
It was also an idea they were going to use
for a Tom Baker doctor who movie during the
4th doctor’s run.
15.
Bad Wolf.
Billie Piper is actually playing Bad Wolf,
she’s playing the living conscience of The
Moment device.
But her appearance is a nod to super goddess
Rose Tyler from series 1.
Sentient Time Lord Technology is also a reference
to Idris.
16.
The Clockwork of the Moment.
Is a nice reference to the repair bots from
Girl in the Fireplace.
17.
The horse.
Is a nod to Arthur, Tennant’s horse from
Girl in the Fireplace.
Allons-y is tennant’s famous doctor’s
call to action.
But he has said it means two different things.
One it’s french for “let’s go” and
two he said during the end of time that it
was a world of consolation to the soul in
times of need.
So it’s kind of like 10s spiritual chicken
soup.
18.
I’m not english.
David tennant is one of the scottish doctors.
So is peter capaldi.
19.
Tennant’s costume.
The outfit he’s wearing is from Series 2,
but the physical costume is one he also took
home after his run on doctor who ended.
Because they didn’t have that many replicas
when it came time to film.
They had to use the one he had kept from way
way back.
He kept one copy of each piece of clothing
10 ever wore.
20.
The Timey Wimey Detector.
It was first used by David Tennant in the
episode Blink.
Later tennant makes a joke at Matt Smith’s
doctor using the term Timey Wimey and says
he has no idea where he gets it from.
21.
Zygons.
They first appeared in the original UNIT story
from Tom Baker’s run Terror of the Zygons.
I think they decided to use UNIT and Kate
Stewart in the episode first and as a result
found it appropriate to use the Zygons as
a nice callback to classic who and Tom Baker.
22.
I’m going to be King.
They did get married and the doctor never
did die technically.
So in reality Matt Smith’s doctor has a
legitimate claim to the throne.
23.
The 5ish doctors stone statues.
In Peter Davison’s parody documentary the
5ish doctors.
the surviving classic doctors try to get into
the 50th anniversary episode and end up becoming
the figures underneath the white cloths pretending
to be statues.
24.
The Blowfish.
They were creatures from the episode Kiss
Kiss Bang Bang on torchwood.
25.
The Fez.
It shows up many times in the episode, but
originally came from the second doctor in
the episode Evil of the Daleks which is one
of the infamous lost episodes.
26.
The cybermen painting is a callback to the
original mondas cybermen design from classic
who.
27.
Overcompensating?
The joke tennant makes is that Matt Smith’s
doctor is “overcompensating” with a flashier
sonic because regeneration is a lottery.
Implying 12 didn’t get the luck of the draw.
But after watching the prequel Night of The
Doctor we know that regeneration doesn’t
have to be random.
28.
Codename Chroma 70s or 80s.
This is a reference to one the chroma restoration
of a lot of black and white doctor who episodes.
The 70s or 80s is a reference to the Third
Doctor’s years which were supposed to be
set in the 80s, but because they were filming
in the 1970s, a lot of 70s references always
made it into those episodes incorrectly.
29.
Reverse the polarity.
Is another phrase coined by the third doctor.
30.
I think there’s three of them now.
Kate stewart answers “there’s a precedent
for that.
She’s talking about the first anniversary
special.
The three doctors.
It was done on the 10th anniversary.
31.
The Black Archive.
The archive was created with the help of the
second or third doctor and has been visited
by Sarah Jane Smith and Martha Jones before
the events of this special.
It’s like UNITs version of the time vaults
on gallifrey.
32.
The wall of fame.
UNIT keeps tabs on the doctor and all his
companions, so everybody from the doctor’s
past is somewhere on the wall here.
33.
Captain Jack’s vortex manipulator.
UNIT took it off him after one of his more
recent deaths.
It’s hard to guess which, because after
his most recent death in Miracle Day he used
a vortex manipulator to travel off world.
So that’s it for the first half of the special.
Be sure to write any extras in the comments
below or if you know any more cool facts about
one in particular.
Like I said, part two will post on saturday.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
I’ve also got a game of thrones and legend
of korra book 3 video coming Friday so you
can watch those on your phones while you’re
out buying stuff.
Right now click here for my review of the
50th and click here for that part 2 video.
I’ll add the annotation after the video
posts on saturday.
Thanks for watching, happy thanksgiving high
fives!